τόσο περισσότερον προσεγγίζουμε η διάγνωση ότι κάθε καρκίνως είναι διαφορετικώς σε κάθε άτομο διαφορετικώς και
χρειάζεται διαφορετική και προσωπική προσαγκηση προσεκεί καθοδηγόμαστε απότις νές εμπερίες και διαγνώσς που μας δίνει
σημερα η γενετικοί τη δυνατότηταν να φωτίσουμε επομένως δεν είναι μια ασθένεια είναι πολλές ασθένις
και γι αυτό τον λόγον υπάρχουν σοβαρές θεναπευτικές αγωγές με τεράστηνες δυνατότητης ίασης σε συγκεκριμένος
καρκίνος και δεύτερο υπάρχει και το πρόβλημα της ιότητας ζωής του καρκενόπαθί που βελτιώνεται και
αυτό και χρόνικά μάλιστα μπορεί σε πολλούς καρκίνος που προηγουμένος δεν μπορούσαμε να το σελέγξουμε
και μέχασε κάποιος μήνες χάνναμε τους ασθενίς τώρα ελέγχονται για πντεξη αυτά χρόνια και αυτά
είναι επίσης δήματα προς την κατι προς τιςσωστη κατεύθηση αλλά το μεγαλύτερον πρόβλημα η ημεγαλύτατο
μεγαλύτερον επίτευγμα δεν είναι ταφάρμακα είναι η έγγαιρι διακωσς εκείναι υ πρόληψη τώρα τηλευταία δημοσιεύθηκε
από το πανεπιστείμε του μονάχου μια μελέτη που είπε ότι τα τελευταία κόπτε χρόνια στον
καρκίνων του μαστού είχαμε μια αύξηση της επιβίωσης κατατριάντα της εκατο